5 26 on your wednesday morning mystery  polls in the middle of the las vegas  strip that's near the welcome to las  vegas sign  if you're just driving by the sign you  might not even notice them especially  with the palm trees keeping an eye on  the cones pedestrians and other traffic  but viewer kurt saw them sending in an  email asking hey do you know what this  is i watch you guys every morning don't  recall this being discussed  well kurt the folks from clark county  tell us those are smart poles they're  combination light poles that have room  to become cell phone sites  so thanks again for writing in kurt  we're going to definitely update you  with more info as we get smarter  about those smart polls in the meantime  buckle up drive carefully please put on  the phone something driving you crazy  email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com